people don't usually meet and go would
you like to potentially wreck your
marriage yes would you oh my god let's
do this yeah like it's much more you
know it slowly happened so when I talk
about types of infidelity
the soulmate the unexpected soul mate
you know this connection that you didn't
expect I didn't expect to fall in love
with this person but I did and the heart
wants what the heart wants and I'm sorry
that one's tough that one's tough
because
you know it's an interesting distinction
between men and women to some degree
that when a man finds out his wife was
cheating the question is did you
him
and when a woman finds out that a man
cheated the question is do you love her
you know and those are those are
different things you know I feel like
there could be many and have been many
books written on them yeah by much
smarter people than me yeah but but
um I I think that
the soulmate thing
is very very painful for a lot of my
female clients when a man says listen I
found the one I found the one and it's
not you
um that that is really really hard to
get past
um
even when it turned out to be true I
mean I've seen some people that you know
it was an affair that turned into 20
plus year marriages you know so I I an
unhappy marriage and then a happy Affair
that turned into a very happy marriage
like I've not seen there's not a formula
you know like I've I've been doing it
long enough now that I've seen
permutations I never would have expected